la régie du logement annonce les
pourcentages applicables pour le calcul
des augmentations des loyers en 2020
pour un logement non chauffé
en additionnant les estimations moyennes
d'augmentation de base et l'estimation
moyenne d'augmentation des taxes
municipales
on arrive à une hausse de 1 9 % pour les
logements non chauffés 1,7 pour cent
pour les logements chauffés à
l'électricité 2,1 pour cent pour les
logements chauffés au gaz 1 3% au mazout
et ça donne donc pour un loyer de 800 $
actuellement par mois une hausse de 10 à
17 dollars ça donne donc 810 108 117
dollars au total
la régie évalue également la hausse pour
les travaux à 2 dollars 58 par tranche
de 1000 $ de rénovation avec nous pour
comprendre tout cela daniel crespo
villarreal avocat chargé de cours en
droit du logement à l'uqam bonsoir
bonsoir commun la régie arrive à ces
pourcentages à ces propositions de
pourcentage d'augmentation
essentiellement ces propositions qui
sont en fait des normes réglementaires
tiennent compte des différents indices
notamment l' indice de près de la
consommation la raison pour laquelle
nous devons attendre jusqu'à aujourd'hui
afin de connaître ses taux la wii parce
qu'on avait les taux d'inflation
aujourd'hui c'est exact mais également
les indices d'augmentation des prix des
hydrocarbures notamment qu'ils vont
jouer un rôle dans le coup de jus du
chauffage et donc vous aviez ajouté
et donc j'allais ajouter que les
chiffres que vous venez de présenter
essentiellement ceux en fait traduisent
une des trois rubriques parce qu'il
n'existe pas seulement ces chiffres là
ces chiffres et la team tiendrez compte
d'une augmentation de taxes municipales
à hauteur de 5%
donc ces chiffres là peuvent varier de
municipalités aux municipalités
advenant le cas par exemple qu'il n'y
ait pas eu d'augmentation de taxes
municipales
les taux les indices serait plus bas ça
va être davantage de l'ordre de 0,6 pour
cent à 1.4 % dépendant du chauffage s'il
est inclus et à travers quelques
l'hydrocarbure parce que le total con
mais là c'est vraiment en incluant une
évaluation d'augmentation des taxes
municipales et une évaluation une
estimation moyenne de hausse au départ
mais ça veut pas dire que les taxes ont
augmenté comme cela exemple ce pourrait
être plus bas c'est exactement de la
même manière
permettez moi d'ajouter ça pourrait être
également plus élevé dépendant de la
réalisation de travaux majeurs donc s'il
y a des immobilisations qui sont reliés
au logement
alors là on se ramasse avec des taux des
indices qui serait davantage de l'ordre
de 2 points 9 à trois points 8 %
dépendant de du chauffage donc qu'elle
ait l'obligation du propriétaire par
rapport à la proposition aujourd'hui de
la régie du logement le propriétaire en
tant que telle est tenu de respecter ces
gens dit cela c'est à dire que si le
locataire conteste une hausse de loyer
qui serait supplémentaires qui ne
seraient pas conformes à ses taux la le
locateur pourrait très bien obtenir gain
de cause devant un tribunal qui dans ce
cas ci la régie du logement se charge de
mettre en oeuvre ces indices là donc le
locataire s'il assiste à une hausse qui
beaucoup plus forte que ce qu'on voit
présentement dans l'outil de calcul là
il peut contester mais s'il ne conteste
pas il vit avec l'augmentation cet
exemple les locataires ont 30 jours à
partir de la date de réception de l'avis
de l'augmentation pour contester pour
s'opposer à cette augmentation là et là
c'est aux propriétaires en fait d'aller
à la régie du logement de déposer une
demande de fixation de loyer qui
viendraient volonté selon les normes
établies
aujourd'hui par règlement donc le
propriétaire l'obligation de respecter
cela en effet et le locataire a le droit
de se défendre
si la hausse n'est pas justifiable cette
exacte vous comprendrez qu ici il ya une
logique il faut surtout comprendre qu'on
est dans une dynamique asymétrique n'est
ce pas s'il ya un lien contractuel qui
est asymétrique pour diverses raisons la
première c'est que voulait dire le
essentiellement c'est que la
contestation d'une augmentation pour un
parent locataires ça veut également dire
le courir le risque de rentrer dans une
relation d'hostilité ou dans un
différend n'est ce pas et courir ce
risque là alors qu'on dépend du
propriétaire du locateur pour fermer un
plombier advenant le cas que d'un
problème de plomberie ou l'exterminateur
s'il ya de la vermine
c'est ça risque que qui peut susciter
des représailles disons donc les
locataires vont toujours être un peu
réticent à se servir des instruments qui
sont en place pour la chose par ailleurs
il faut également tenir compte que les
données pour l'augmentation de loyer les
données qui doivent être prises en
compte soit les frais d'entretien ou les
frais de gestion par exemple
ne sont pas accessibles aux locataires
donc le locataire n'est pas en mesure de
connaître et fait de savoir si
effectivement l'augmentation proposée
est conforme au règlement de leur côté
la corpiq dit que les critères pour ce
qui est du de la possibilité d'augmenter
en fonction des travaux qu'on fait on
est à 2 dollars 58 par tranche de 1000 $
de rénovation que ça va venir accentuer
les problèmes de disponibilité de
qualité et que ça va prendre une
éternité finalement pour les
propriétaires à rentabiliser ou intégrés
c'est mon talent est ce que est ce qu'on
devrait aller plus loin du côté de la
régie du logement dans un contexte de
crise du logement aidé selon les
chiffres qui sont d'autres augmentations
de loyer des dernières années ça serait
un peu difficile de prétendre
effectivement que ces repaires la c1 dit
cela serve effectivement comme rempart
de protection pour les hausses de loyer
plus élevé n'est ce pas cela dit la
corpiq a raison dans la mesure où il est
vrai que c'est très difficile de éponger
si on veut ces rénovations la via des
hausses de loyer si on se conforme au
règlement
la question à se poser c'est est-ce que
c'est le rôle du loyer que d'éponger
c'est ce type de réparation
parce que malgré qu'il y ait des
améliorations locatives il faut aussi
tenir compte du fait qu'il y ait une
augmentation de la valeur de la maison
oui et c'est en ce sens que il est
toujours profitable est toujours
rentable pour un propriétaire
d'appartements locatifs à revenus de
procéder à des réparations dans un
contexte comme celui ci où est ce que il
ya effectivement une spéculation
immobilière et où est ce que le coût des
des maisons l'évaluation des maisons
augmente d'année en année
au delà de l'inflation et notamment par
une question de 2,2 de la manière dont
on organise la fiscalité municipale
n'est ce pas est-ce qu'on devrait ce que
vous pensez qu'on devrait améliorer ce
système d'augmentation du loyer ce qu'on
devrait plus précis plus série au
chapitre de l'encadrement le règlement
les indices servent déjà quelque chose
on peut pas réinventer la roue par an ce
qu'on pourrait faire effectivement ça
serait d'améliorer la mise en oeuvre de
ces indices là c'est à dire de la
manière dont on les exécutent par
exemple en envoyant davantage de 2
de moyens à la régie du logement qui est
l'entité administrative et judiciaire
qui se charge de traiter ces choses là
il ya beaucoup de personnes tant
propriétaires comme locataires qui vont
hésiter à recourir à ce tribunal pour
des raisons simples de ne pas vouloir
voir dossier traîner pendant des mois et
des mois et donc créer un sentiment
d'animosité entre les deux parties d'un
autre côté on peut être imaginatif n'est
ce pas il ya toujours la possibilité de
renverser changer la personne sur qui
repose le fardeau de la fixation de
loyer par exemple quand je vous disais
un locataire va souvent hésité pour
avant de contester une augmentation
alors si on obligeait carrément si on si
le statu quo était simplement la
stabilité des loyers etc ont forcé le
propriétaire a augmenté le loyer à
travers une demande de la régie du
logement
ça pourrait dans ce sens aider à la
stabilisation puisqu'il aurait quand
même droit à une augmentation conforme
au règlement
monsieur crespo villarreal merci
beaucoup merci à vous merci